this was the moment lionel messi turned
the page
after the tears of his barcelona exit on
sunday the world's biggest football star
was all business
focused on the job of winning a first
champions league title for his new club
paris
i've come to help to give my maximum i
come with great enthusiasm with more
desire than ever many times i've said it
that my goal and my dream is to win the
champions league again and i think this
is the ideal place to have more
opportunities to achieve that
people had been gathered outside the
park depressed since the weekend but it
was the arrival of the ultras that was a
demonstration not just of psg spending
power but of the further of their
supporters
after the days of waiting this cheering
behind us tells us that lionel messi has
finally come out here at the part of
france to meet the paris ashama fans
the messi circus will now tour the
country for the liga season
bringing superstardom on another level
to provincial towns
messi part of a dream lineup including
the likes of brazil star neymar and
spain's sergio ramos it would be crazy
everywhere he would go it would be like
the i don't know the harlem
globetrotters but times 10 even you know
this is the phd all-stars it's not just
messi actually it's all the others
people impressed and loyal never thought
they would ever see leonardo messi play
live and now they have that chance so
it's going to be special i feel for the
people in trois because troi was the
first game of the season for psg and
messi wasn't there so they'll have to
wait next season if they're still in
ligand
before they can see it messi was offered
the number 10 shirt he wore at barcelona
but took 30 instead his first squad
number two decades ago psg hope his
arrival will mean their number seven
france striker killian in bappe also
stays boston in the future
killian is very competitive and creates
the mentality to win he said publicly
that he wants a competitive team and now
i don't think there's a more competitive
team than this and that means that he
doesn't have an excuse to do any other
thing
the formalities of the medical his 41
million contract and his unveiling over
now it's time for messi to step on the
pitch
he should do that at training this week
and in a match for real by the end of
the month
paul reese al jazeera paris